حديث صادر عن بنتك السعوديه عن تضاعف عدد
شركات التقنيه الماليه في السعوديه بنحو
15 ضعفا وذلك منذ 2018 كما كشفت تقرير
ايضا عن حجم استثمارات تصل الى اربعه
مليارات ريال وفي نظره تاريخيه لتطور قطاع
التقنيه الماليه في السعوديه نجد بان
نواته الاولى كانت عام
1990 عندما اطلقت وزاره الماليه خدمه مدى
وفي عام 99 اطلق المركزي السعودي خدمه
سداد في ما جاءت الانطلاقه الكبرى عام
2018 مع اطلاق مبادره تنتك السعوديه
استراتيجيه التقنيه الماليه مشاهدينا
والتي تعد الركيزه الرابعه لبرنامج تطوير
القطاع المالي الذي اطلق في عام 2017
تهدفه بحلول 20 30 الى خلقه 18,000 وظيفه
و50 شركه
النيه بالاضافه الى وصول حجم مساهمه
القطاع في الناتج المحلي الى ثلاثه عشر
وثلاثه من 10 مليار ريال وحول انشطه
التقنيه الماليه نجد بان نشاطي تمويل
الملكيه الجماعيه والتمويل الجماعي
العقاري
تستحوذان على الحصه الاكبر من حجم ناشطه
القطاع ب 29% لكل منهما فيما تشكل ادوات
الدين كما نشاهد 17%
و16% للمستثمر الالي
اعداد الشركات مشاهدينا لقطاع التقنيه
الماليه سجلت نموا كبيرا حيث كان عدد
الشركات للقطاع العام في 2018 10 شركات
فقط
لتتضاعف منذ ذلك لتصل اليوم الى
147 شركه في العام الحالي الشركات العامله
مشاهدينا اليوم في السعوديه تقعوا مقراتو
87% منها في السعوديه فيما تتوزع مقرات
المقرات على المقراتها 13% الاخرى على دول
اخرى وحوله مجالات شركات التقنيه الماليه
في السعوديه
تستحوذ كمان نشاهد شركات المدفوعات وصرف
العملات على النصيب الاكبر باثنين وخمسين
شركه فيما جاءت ثانيا شركاته حلول الاعمال
وتوفير المعلومات بس 26 شركه فيما جاء عدد
البنوك الرقميه في السعوديه
بثلاثه وحول معد نموم مجالات شركات القطاع
جاء مجال البنيه التحتيه الاعلى نموا كما
نشاهد ب 600 في المئه يليه مجال التمويل
الشخصي واداره الخزينه ب 100
و75% في مكان الاقل نموا مجال الاقراض
والتمويل
42% وحولها شركات التقنيه المسجله في
قاعده بيانات تنتك السعوديه شكلت الشركات
في مرحله التشغيل الكامل ال 21% في ما لا
تزال 9% من الشركات في مرحله تصريح البيئه
التجريبيه اما مرحله الفكره فتشكل النسبه
الاكبر بسبعه 37% من الشركات وهو ما يعطي
تصورا عن القفزه الكبيره المنتظره لهذا
القطاع في السعوديه خلال السنوات القريبه
القادمه